bienvenidos a mi presentación sobre
títulos respaldados por hipotecas así
que empecemos y esta presentación
formará parte de una nueva serie de
presentaciones porque creo que es muy
importante y muy relevante lo que está
pasando actualmente con los créditos que
da el mercado porque ésta tiene un
significado muy importante creo en un
punto de vista financiero o al menos en
las finanzas propias y también en un
contexto histórico mi intención es hacer
un buén de vídeos para que con ello las
personas entiendan como todo está
relacionado y cuáles son las
repercusiones que éstas pueden tener
pero bueno tenemos que empezar con lo
básico que son los títulos respaldados
por hipotecas o también llamados los
valores hipotecarios respaldados bueno
primeramente vamos a verlo en un
contexto histórico así que supongamos
que yo necesito un préstamo para comprar
una casa donde quedo mi pluma y aquí
está un préstamo de 100 mil nada mejor
de un millón de pesos le voy a pedir al
banco una deuda de un millón de pesos
para que pueda comprar mi casa y bueno
este préstamo va a ser una hipoteca
sobre el valor de la casa esto qué
quiere decir
el banco pone una seguridad sobre tu
casa es decir si tú no le pagas entonces
se cobrará con toda tu casa es decir le
estoy pidiendo al banco un millón de
pesos para comprar mi casa y si no puedo
pagar esta deuda entonces el banco lo
que va a hacer es llegar y quitarme mi
casa y no sólo eso sino que también mi
historial crediticio quedaría manchado
así que vamos a verlo con un dibujito
este sonriente soy yo y este de aquí es
el banco y el banco es el que tiene el
dinero por lo tanto yo llego al banco y
el banco me va a prestar mi millón de
pesos entonces me presta un millón de
pesos y además de ese millón de pesos yo
le voy a tener que pagar un cierto
interés entonces ahorita hablamos de
números y yo sé que el interés va
reduciéndose en lo que va pasando el
tiempo vamos a ver vídeos acerca del
interés pero vamos a suponer que el
interés es fijo y es del 10% para este
vídeo y no nos compliquemos más y aunque
ahorita estamos hablando de interés fijo
lo que sí les quiero comentar es que en
general como se ven estas deudas son un
interés compuesto lo que quiere decir es
en cada uno de tus pagos tú vas a pagar
una cierta cantidad de interés y además
vas a pagar una cierta cantidad de tu
deuda
lo que va a hacer que tu deuda vaya
disminuyendo pero en este tipo de
interés las matemáticas se vuelven un
poquito más difíciles por lo tanto para
simplicidad de este vídeo voy a suponer
que el interés es fijo y además que al
final del tiempo en el que te presten el
dinero tú vas a tener que pagar todo ese
dinero vamos a suponer que este dinero
me lo prestan durante 10 años y también
recuerdan que tengo que pagar un 10 por
ciento de interés anual es decir en cada
uno de los años tengo que pagar 100 mil
pesos de interés y en el año 10 lo que
voy a tener que pagar es mi interés de
100 mil pesos por año y además voy a
tener que regresar les el millón de
pesos completo para que se entienda
mejor aquí tengo los 10 años y lo que va
a pasar es que en el primer año pagó 100
mil en el segundo 100 mil en el tercero
100 mil en el noveno año 100 mil y en el
décimo año voy a pagar los 100 mil más
el millón de pesos por lo tanto voy a
pagar 1.1 millones de pesos y esta va a
ser la forma con la cual va a
interactuar mi dinero con el banco ojo
recuerden que estamos tomando una taza
de interés constante y esto era para que
la presentación fuera mucho más sencilla
porque
vídeo recuerdan que lo más importante es
que les hable acerca de los títulos
respaldados por hipotecas es decir lo
importante es que en esta ecuación el
banco se va a quedar con la deuda y esto
históricamente es lo que pasa cuando yo
tengo una deuda con el banco durante
diez años ahora te voy a meter a ti en
este cuento entonces tú eres esta
persona que estoy dibujando y además
tienes un sombrero y además tú tienes
mucho dinero entonces llegas con el
banco y tú vas a depositar al banco un
millón de pesos lo que quieres es que el
banco cuide tu dinero
estos son los ahorros de toda tu vida o
mejor vamos a suponer que es la herencia
de tu tío millonario y entonces el banco
te dice que por quedarse tu dinero él te
va a pagar una tasa de interés del 5%
anual y entonces el banco nada tonto lo
que va a pasar es que me va a dar a mí
ese millón de pesos para pagar yo mi
casa y él me va a cobrar una tasa de
interés del 10% y entonces aquí en una
diferencia a ti te va a dar el 5% y el
otro 5% es para el banco y así es como
funciona el préstamo cuando nosotros
hablamos del título respaldado por
hipotecas
vamos a ver una nueva pantalla en donde
existe yo y también existo con una deuda
de un millón de pesos por lo tanto voy
al banco también aquí tengo al banco y
entonces este de aquí es el banco está
muy bien dibujado mi banco y el banco
tiene mucho dinero y el banco lo que va
a hacer es prestarme un millón de pesos
entonces me presta un millón de pesos y
también le voy a pagar una cierta tasa
interés que va a ser la misma el 10 por
ciento de interés anual y bueno se
parece mucho el modelo viejo pero la
diferencia es que aquí vamos a innovar
todo el asunto en esta ocasión en lugar
de que el banco se esté quedando con
todos los depósitos lo que va a decir el
banco es porque no vendo mis préstamos
voy a vender mis préstamos a un tercero
y bueno yo sé que esto es una muy
confuso cómo voy a vender un préstamo
pero bueno es que aquí estoy yo pero
supongamos que hay un ejército de ellos
es decir aquí voy a tener a miles de
salman hay un montón de sal en este
mundo y cada uno de estos sal debe
dinero al banco
para que no sea un número muy grande voy
a suponer que somos 1000 lo mejor es que
todos le debemos un millón de pesos al
banco por lo tanto un millón por mil
me dan mil millones entonces
colectivamente debemos mil millones al
banco y colectivamente estamos pagando
todos el 10% de la tasa de interés anual
el interés fijo es decir estamos pagando
un 10% de estos mil millones de pesos y
el 10% de mil millones de pesos es lo
mismo que 100 millones de pesos entonces
el banco dice lo siguiente yo acabo de
prestar mil millones de pesos y aunque
no es un dinero físico digo esto lo
tengo en la base de datos este vídeo se
lo estoy dando a cada una de estas
personas y lo que va a decir es si tu
banco de inversión si otro banco porque
tu banco de inversión no me das no sé
mil millones de pesos y bueno ya que
tenemos a toda esta gente que me está
pagando a mí una cierta tasa de interés
que les parece si toda esta gente le
paga mejor
el nuevo banco al banco de inversión
entonces todos estos le van a pagar al
banco de inversión creo que los hay en
un poco confuso cuando el banco original
vende todos estos préstamos
todos estos préstamos que tenía en su
base de datos junto a todos sus
préstamos en un mismo préstamo y esto es
lo que le va a pedir al otro banco que
ahora el banco original le tiene todo el
dinero y el segundo banco lo que tiene
es todas las deudas o todos los
préstamos y le bueno la pregunta va a
ser porque el banco original hizo esto y
creo que ya no tengo mucho tiempo para
darles todos los detalles pero pueden
pasar varias cosas pero puede ser que el
banco original obtenga varios honorarios
por hacer esto o no sé tal vez
simplemente lo único que les guste es
pasar las deudas de sus clientes a otros
bancos para realmente la respuesta
correcta sería que el obtiene ciertos
honorarios por esto dicho de otra manera
tal vez lo que hace es quedarse con una
cierta parte de la tasa de interés bueno
estoy suponiendo que ahora entiendes un
poco más a lo que me refiero con pasar
la deuda a otro banco y me he gastado
dos minutos de este vídeo para
explicarles un poquito de esto es es lo
que me voy a fijar en el siguiente vídeo
es que este tipo va a convertir este
préstamo en un título de respaldo por
hipotecas este tipo de bancos que se
llaman bancos de inversión así que no se
lo pierdan nos vemos en el siguiente